can you give me the origins of the
hatchet man logo yeah man that everyone
has tattooed in the very beginning me
and Joey me and Shaggy he's like um we
had two we had two ideas for a label
name one was one was a great name mad
paper boy right and and it was going to
be a guy on a bike with a with a um a
[__] newspaper like like like the
game and we wanted to call it back then
this is before paper was known as money
though because um there was a [__]
paper boy used to come through looking
like [__] Napoleon Dynamite kind of
right and and [__] throwing papers
everywhere and um he was our boy we love
to see him so we were like how about mad
paper uh records and um I thought that
would have been cool the other one was
Psychopathic you know it's same idea but
now it's just a guy with a instead of a
paper he's got the uh the um hatchet man
you know what I mean